more than a thousand mourners are
expected to attend the funeral today a
former first lady barbara Bush mrs. Bush
died at her home in Houston on Tuesday
she was 92 years old former President
Bill Clinton and his wife Hillary and
former President Barack Obama and his
wife Michelle are among those expected
First Lady Melania Trump will be there
but president Trump will not attend
bianna golodryga is outside st. Martin's
Episcopal Church in Houston where 1500
mourners are expected at the funeral
beyond a good morning Anthony good
morning and this is where those 1,500
mourners will be gathering and to give
you a sense of how beloved the bushes
are in this city I spent some time with
the family pastor this week who said
he's been fielding calls for days now
from congregants and non congregants
puzzled as to why they weren't invited
as well saying but we were such good
friends with the bushes and they weren't
wrong the bushes seem to be friends with
everyone here thousands of Houstonians
some friends some strangers lined up
Friday to pay their respects to the
former first lady at the church where
she and her husband attended services
for over five decades former President
George HW Bush and daughter Dorothy
pause at the casket before thanking
well-wishers
it's all been part of a two-day
celebration of life for the beloved
matriarch who died Tuesday at age 92 the
funeral today will be attended by four
former presidents along with First Lady
Melania Trump there will also be some
1500 invited guests everybody feels like
they've lost a friend a role model
someone of great inspiration Bush family
pastor Reverend dr. Russell Levinson jr.
lead the eulogy I don't know how you
asked her over in this but I'm going to
do it are you prepared are you ready I
am prepared because I think my task is
the priest and pastor to this home and
his family is to honor her and you
thanks for her remarkable life to
celebrate her faith mrs. Bush impacted
people in unexpected ways says Quentin
Richardson it was a statement that she
made about teach a person to read and
you unlock their life to unknown
possibilities and that stuck with me
Richardson is one of 17 Houston barbers
that partnered with the Barbara Bush
literacy program that supplied all the
books for these small libraries in their
shops her spirit and her efforts and the
fruits of her work are being still
enjoyed today people will read to their
children 15 minutes or more every day
it'd be a complete game-changer
two years ago Houston Texans linebacker
JJ Watt teamed up with mrs. Bush in this
PSA to help tackle illiteracy watt says
he built a friendship with mrs. Bush
which he believes inspired his
charitable work to help the victims of
Hurricane Harvey I'm thankful for the
fact that she she showed me what it's
like to be a light for other people
obviously throughout her entire life she
campaigned for literacy but also just
she she was she was about service of
others and throughout their lives the
bushes have raised more than 1 billion
dollars for charities like cancer
charities and literacy charities as well
the president and his wife did a lot of
planning for today's service she in fact
picked the eulogists will include which
will include Jeb Bush and family
biographer Jon Meacham following the
service the body will be driven the
procession will be driven about an hour
and a half north of here to College
Station where Barbara Bush will be laid
to rest next to her her beloved daughter
Robin who died from leukemia at the age
of three Dana
bianna golodryga and Houston bianna
thank you she was such a spirited woman
I love those pictures because I picked
her up her shoulder pads I mean I told
you on Twitter I loved seeing a picture
of her detail standing by Secret Service
detail yes and and being there no matter
what no matter what yeah tells you their
commitment